I'm the founder and developer of this
thing called the auto motor Plex is
first of its type of private garage
condominium complex that caters toward
vehicle enthusiasts
we have been in existence since one one
overweight and we sold out about roughly
a year ago there are a number of reasons
why people decide to join us but they're
clearly like three drivers one is you're
out of space I realized I ran out of
room of my primary residence second one
even if you have space at home your
items your cars are really not safe but
even if you have the nicest garage in
the world you're all alone and here
you're surrounded by like-minded
enthusiasts I'm so glad that I didn't
try to do this on my own because this is
a community of guys like me all of these
cars I have restored if I want to go to
a car show at best I can take one car
maybe two I just open the door and I got
twenty cars in a car show at the end of
the day is far far less than what you'd
spend at a golf Country Club we have a
golf simulator on average garage I would
say is more like the thousand to 1500
square foot that's gonna be somewhere
between 150 to 200 thousand to purchase
and then they're ready for people to
come in and put their final finishing
sign
this is my getaway spot every grads
leaves one this is a wine cellar I
probably have you know in the structure
in the build out about $600,000 worth of
investment and then the car is hard to
put a value on them and their art people
like art on walls or in books and things
like that I kind of like them on four
and two wheels we're agnostic when it
comes down to brand if it's got an
engine or a cylinder attached to it
we're excited somebody shows up an eight
horsepower lawnmower awesome we have two
snowmobiles we have two motorcycles we
have two scooters is a variety of toys
not the big powerhouse set of toys that
I would people have out here but it fits
us this is our man cave bathroom we love
that play aspect of it up here this is
our fun cave this is our staycation
there's definitely a market for this
around the country not just around the
country around the globe now if it could
be done in Minneapolis I would think it
could be done a lot of different places